CHRIS DEFAY: All right, hello,
my name's Chris DeFay.
And this is a Talks at Google
Presentation here in Google's
Los Angeles office.
We are very pleased today to
welcome author and musician
Ian Whitcomb.
Ian is a native of Surrey,
England, and a current
resident of Altadena, northeast
of downtown Los
Angeles, and has been
entertaining
the world for decades.
After hitting the American Top
10 charts in 1965 with his
novelty record "You Turn Me On"
and finding himself in the
company of young bands like The
Rolling Stones, he devoted
his work to resurrecting the
roots of pop music, especially
ragtime and Tin Pan Alley.
He's performed everywhere, from
the Hollywood Bowl, to
the Montreux Jazz Festival,
and has appeared on Johnny
Carson, "The Tonight Show." As
an author he has published
over 20 books, and is best known
for his book, "After the
Ball," on the history of pop
music from rag to rock.
Today he will be discussing the
topic of his recent book,
"Ukulele Heroes, the Golden
Age," and playing us a few
samples, I think.
IAN WHITCOMB: I'll try.
CHRIS DEFAY: Yes.
Please join me in
welcoming Ian.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN WHITCOMB: Thank you.
First of all, how
many of you here
actually play the ukulele?
Good, great, well I used to
be a very good player.
But I had an illness, and
I can't strum very well.
Here's the ukulele.
This is a Martin, one of the
best ones you can get.
It's nice.
I call this a pleasingly
plangent sound.
[UKULELE PLAYING]
IAN WHITCOMB: So it's a
four-stringed instrument.
And I'll give you a little brief
history, but not too
much of it.
I want to questions
from you all too.
Brief history is that it was
actually not invented in
Hawaii at all.
It was invented by
the Portuguese.
It was called a machete there.
In fact, there's a picture in
1860 of the girl who became
Alice in "Alice in Wonderland"
playing her machete.
And it was brought across to
Hawaii by Portuguese who were
working in the plantations then,
the sugar plantations.
And they had four of them on
board a ship called the
"Raven's Crag," which
had arrived in 1878.
And the Hawaiians immediately
took to this instrument, which
they called it ukulele, or
oo-kah-lay-lee, as they say in
Hawaii, which means jumping
or leaping flea.
And they loved it, especially
the royalty, Hawaiian royalty.
At that time it was
a free country.
That was just before America
came in and acquired, well,
shall we say they overthrew
the queen.
We won't go into that.
It's a sore point
for Hawaiians.
It was a bloodless revolution,
or rebellion, or whatever,
takeover , by American
businessmen in
the pineapple business.
But anyway, it's
all in my book.
The point is the last queen,
whose name I can't pronounce,
who's on the cover of my book.
I should know her name.
Some of you may know her name.
She was a wonderful composer.
And she wrote great songs.
She wrote the famous "Aloha
Oe." It sounds Jewish.
It's not, "Aloha Oe." And
she played the piano.
And she survived the overthrow
of the country.
The steel guitar, by the
way, was actually
invented by the Hawaiians.
That's where you pull a metal
bar across the strings.
They did actually invent that.
They didn't invent
the ukulele.
But they did invent this slide
guitar, which, of course, is
now associated very much
with blues and country.
But it actually comes
from Hawaii.
So they can claim that one.
I won't get too historical, but
what happened was that,
eventually, the mainlanders, as
they call us, got to hear
about the ukulele.
In 1915, there was an exposition
in San Francisco
called the Pan-Pacific
Exposition.
And the Hawaiians had
their own pavilion.
And they sent across their
bands, which were the most
popular things of all, these
Hawaiian bands with ukuleles
and steel guitars.
And, more importantly, hula
girls swaying because the
hula, although it's a religious
dance, we see it as
sort of a sexy dance
from the hips.
But the Hawaiians don't
think that.
They think it's a very
religious dance.
Anyway, the hula girls and the
Hawaiian bands were extremely
popular in America in 1915.
So much so that Tin Pan Alley,
in New York where they wrote-
I guess you all know what
Tin Pan Alley is.
It's where they manufactured
popular songs.
They were all published
in sheet music form.
And Tin Pan Alley realized
this was a phenomena.
So they started writing songs
about Hawaii and what a
blissful place it was.
So Hawaiian bands toured
America, became very popular,
especially in the south, where
the southerners loved the
steel guitar.
And that's why you have the
steel guitar in country music,
because of Hawaiian bands
touring the country.
Now I should just tell you
about myself a bit more.
I was, as what Chris explained,
I was a teen idol
for a short time in the '60s.
Probably nobody remembers "You
Turn Me On," do they?
Anybody remember that song,
"You Turn Me On"?
It was top 10, top
number eight.
I think you do.
In 1965, I was in the top 10,
the same time that the song
"Satisfaction" was number one.
Anyway, quickly I realized
that rock and
roll was not my field.
So I started--
I bought a ukulele in a
pawnshop, P-A-W-N, in Los
Angeles, a Martin.
And I immediately began playing
the uke on the bus
tours that I did with these
rock and roll groups.
And a group called The Turtles
heard me and said, you ought
to record some of these songs.
So I did.
I've been recording the
older songs since.
And my whole career has gone
backwards because of that.
But I was playing ukulele.
And my version of this 1916
song, "Where Did Robinson
Crusoe Go with Friday on
Saturday Night?" became a hit
and established me
as a uke player.
And I suppose, in a way, I
started the whole uke revival
because this was before Tiny
Tim, who is associated with--
This is from a song book I've
got out called "Ian Whitcomb's
Ukulele Sing-Along." It's a
nice little book with a CD
attached, which you
can get online.
And it sells quite well.
Anyway, we've reached the point
where Tin Pan Alley is
cashing in on the
Hawaiian craze.
And in America, people
are buying ukuleles.
The Martin company begins
to build the ukulele.
If you have any questions ask
them anytime you like.
So, yes, a question?
AUDIENCE: Did you say a date or
a decade when the ukulele
was introduced by the Portuguese
to Hawaii?
IAN WHITCOMB: Yes, well they
came over in a ship, the three
of them, in 1878, in the
"Raven's Crag." They landed in
Hawaii, in Honolulu.
And they were all craftsmen.
They had the ukuleles
with them.
And many of them could
build ukes.
And so the first ukuleles were
built by Portuguese craftsmen.
And then they gradually, as I
said, it became popular from
about 1915.
And then the mainlanders
began to make ukes.
Although Hawaii still makes
very good ukes.
If you want to buy one, by the
way, my friend who put this
out, Jim Beloff has a very good
company called Fluke,
F-L-U-K-E, and they make
really good ukes.
They're designed by
an MIT engineer.
They're partly wood and
partly plastic.
They have a beautiful sound.
So that's Jim Beloff.
His email address is
fleamarketmusic.com.
AUDIENCE: I was curious because
Mark Twain was in
Hawaii in the 1860s.
I was wondering if he
would have heard it.
IAN WHITCOMB: There wouldn't
have been a ukulele then.
The Portuguese had
it in the 1860s.
It was called a machete.
It never really caught on.
It was only when the Portuguese
brought it to Hawaii.
And then the Hawaiians
loved it.
They called it the ukulele,
jumping flea, and then it got
popularized from then.
They really developed the
whole strumming style.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did they keep
the same tuning?
IAN WHITCOMB: No, the original
tuning was different.
That tuning I have there is the
standard, G-C-E-A, my dog
has fleas, but in the old days,
the early days it was
actually different tuning.
It was much higher.
But it got standardized.
If you look at old sheet music,
you'll see that they
have from the '20s onwards--
I'm playing around with
my technology--
if you look at the old sheet
music, and today, they have
these little grids that show you
where to put your fingers.
Those were invented
about 1920.
And if you look at any old sheet
music from that period,
it'd say ukulele arrangement.
The reason is, and I should
get back to this point, is
that by that time the ukulele
had become really popular,
very trendy.
In the 1920s, in the Jazz Age,
it was the trend to play a
saxophone, or play the drums,
or play the ukulele.
That's why you see these young
men in raccoon cotes playing
the ukulele.
It was the way to woo
your girlfriend.
In fact, I have experience
with that
because- not in the 20s.
But when I had a-- before
I met Regina,
I had a lady friend.
I once sang on the beach to her,
you were meant for me,
with my uke, and she
took it seriously.
She said, do you mean that?
Are you serious about that?
I realized then the power of
these old popular songs.
They're very powerful songs.
It doesn't apply today, because
people shout today,
and they rant.
And I can't understand what
they're talking about.
But in those days there were
very romantic songs, which hit
the nail squarely on the head.
So I love those songs.
That's why I'm still very
involved with old songs.
I write books about songs.
I love old songs.
By the way, if you go on
YouTube, you can see some
videos I made with an Akai.
I don't know if you know the
Akai, reel to reel, was an
early prototype video recorder,
portable one.
I had one and I went to New York
with it, and I videoed
all the old songwriters I could
find, including the man
who wrote "Swanny" with George
Gershwin, Irving Caesar..
And these are all up online
now on YouTube.
You can see me.
You can see my interview with
Johnny Marks, who wrote
"Rudolph, the Red-Nosed
Reindeer." You can see me--
if you type in--
I think he's doing it now.
Type in Ian Whitcomb, Harry
Warren, who's a great
songwriter, who wrote "Home in
Pasadena." You can see he and
I singing that song together.
And I'm accompanying
him on the ukulele.
He sings what he calls
an obbligato part.
He was a great man.
So I, early on, when these
songwriters were still alive,
I took my video camera.
And I videoed them, as
many as I could.
Eubie Blake, who lived to
be 100, I videoed him.
I wish I'd done more of this.
I mean, they're all dead now.
But it was a wonderful- I was
so glad that I did that.
G-C-E-A. [SINGING]
My dog has fleas, fleas,
my dog has fleas.
And it's easy to play.
The basic, the first
C chord is--
[UKULELE PLAYING]
IAN WHITCOMB: And then G 7th.
IAN WHITCOMB: F.
[UKULELE PLAYING]
IAN WHITCOMB: Pleasant
sound, isn't it?
I used to be much stronger.
But I had an illness.
Which I'm recovering from,
by the way, folks.
I'll just tell you know.
I had a stroke about
nine months ago.
So I'm doing my best.
I hope you can understand
what I'm saying.
I survived the stroke.
But I'm still--
my fingers are still bad.
I can't feel much
in this hand.
They keep telling me it
will all come back.
I'm working on it every day.
My wife's a great help.
Anyway, got that
out of the way.
I'm still performing.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IAN WHITCOMB: I'm left-handed.
I'm left-handed, so it means
that I can't play the piano
well now with my left hand.
But I won't go into all that.
I've survived.
And I can talk.
And I can walk.
And I can be annoying.
By the way, I'm sorry
I'm plugging myself.
But if you're interested, I
have a radio show every
Wednesday night on a site
called Luxuriamusic.com.
It's a nice company,
LuxuriaMusic.
And I do it live.
It'll be on tomorrow night,
Wednesday night.
If you really enjoy what I'm
saying, if you go online and
just put in Ian Whitcomb
podcast, there are 93 radio
shows that I did for XM.
I used to work for
a company called
Premiere Radio Networks.
And amongst the radio shows
they make the most
money off, not mine.
They make money off Rush
Limbaugh, Sean Hannity--
Years to come, because the
CDs will all fade.
We'll be left with LPs, which
will last forever, and '78s,
which, if you're careful with
them, are wonderful things.
That's my little speech
about technology.
I never understood why I see
all these kids going around
with these things stuck in their
ears because the sound
on MP3s is terrible.
They'll never hear what good
sound sounds like.
Good sound is an LP played
through a good turntable.
That's what I think.
And if you've got anything to
challenge me on that tell me.
I'm an old technologist.
I prefer old technology.
AUDIENCE: Are you going to talk
later about certain, more
recent resurgences
of the ukulele?
IAN WHITCOMB: Well,
I do in the book.
Of course, there's been
the resurgence.
I didn't get to that.
Sorry, I should quickly skip
to that before we get onto
Ukulele Ike.
Well, the ukulele was very
popular, as I was saying, in
the '20s and the '30s.
And then it started
to fade away.
And with the coming of
rock and roll, it
was completely out.
When I was playing the
ukulele in the '60s,
people laughed at me.
It became a joke instrument.
Of course, Tiny Tim
didn't help that.
And it went out for a while
until the resurgence, which is
started on this West Coast,
which is where most new things
begin, on the West Coast.
LA is a much better place than
New York, by the way.
This is where we develop the
new things, in LA and
California.
Anyway, it started to
have a comeback.
It's huge now.
Everybody's playing
the ukulele.
Warren Buffett plays it.
And, as I was saying before,
if you watch any Pixar film
they always have a ukulele
in every scene.
They love ukulele.
They hired me to come up there
and teach them to teach the
directors to play the ukulele.
So it's having a huge
comeback, why?
Because it's very simple.
It may be something to
do with the economy.
It's an easy instrument
to play.
You don't have to plug it in.
You don't have to buy
amplifiers and have
complicated, sophisticated
equipment.
It's easy to play.
And it's very pleasant.
Everybody loves the
sound of it.
It's a very, very peaceful
instrument.
I believe the whole world's
problems of the world could be
solved if we all just marched
into trouble spots with our
ukes and just strummed.
I say that in the book.
I get into that in the book.
Yes, Regina?
REGINA: Taylor Swift says, right
from the stage when she
plays the ukulele, she thinks
it has the friendliest sound
of any instrument.
IAN WHITCOMB: It's
very friendly.
You couldn't hit anybody
with a ukulele.
You couldn't rob them
or murder them.
[LAUGHTER]
IAN WHITCOMB: It's a very
safe instrument to play.
I know.
But anyway, I was saying- did
I explain the resurgence
properly, sir?
AUDIENCE: The other thing I've
noticed is that teenagers,
like anything else, and maybe
this hasn't contributed to the
popularity, but most teens that
I know that have picked
it up at least began
to learn through
watching YouTube videos.
There's thousands of hours.
IAN WHITCOMB: YouTube has lots
of videos of people playing
it, how to play.
It's an easy instrument
to play.
Anybody can play it.
It's great fun just to learn
a few chords and
sing along at parties.
It's so popular.
As I said, I feel that I did
play a little small part in
having it become
popular again.
And I've always loved
the sound of it.
You can play any chord
on the uke.
It's a wonderful instrument.
Well, let's just get back to
the '20s if I may, and hear
Ukulele Ike.
We talked about scat singing.
He did this- he called
it eefing.
Ukulele Ike's real name
was Cliff Edwards.
He had a very checkered life.
If you read the book,
I hope people have
copies of the book.
You'll see there's a whole
chapter on Ukulele Ike, Cliff
Edwards, and his sad life.
He was born in the
same town as Mark
Twain, Hannibal, Missouri.
In fact, he met Mark Twain.
But anyway, in the '20s he
became very popular with his
records playing his ukulele.
And then in the '30s, he
made lots of films.
He's probably best known today
because he lent his voice to
the sound of Jiminy Cricket in
"Pinocchio." He sings, very
sweetly, "When You Wish Upon a
Star" in the opening credits
of that film.
That's Cliff Edwards.
He died.
He was a gambler.
He had trouble with his wives.
He had so many wives.
He spent all his money, drink
and gambling, and died
penniless and unknown
in Hollywood.
His body lay unclaimed
for days.
Finally, the Walt Disney company
paid for him to have a
grave, which is actually out
by Bob Hope Airport now.
You can go and visit him.
Ukulele Ike's stuff
is all available--
are you all enjoying this
talk by the way?
I can see you all smiling.
Am I talking too fast?
One of the results of my stroke
is that I speak too
fast, and my tongue
gets tripped.
I trip my tongue, but anyway,
as long as you can hear what
I'm saying, and I'm being
articulate, that's great.
I can see all your
smiling faces.
Well now, we're getting towards
the end of our examples.
And I'd love to have
more questions.
In England, the ukulele was very
popular, largely through
a man called George Formby.
He's a hero in England, an
absolute national hero.
He started recording
in the 1930s.
He made films, Ealing Films,
which were the most popular
films in the British
box office.
And he made songs
in World War II.
He played a banjo ukulele.
But it looks like a banjo.
It has a much stronger sound.
He had an incredible strum,
which if you go on YouTube,
you can see people
demonstrate.
It's very, very hard to do.
He had a syncopated strum.
He recorded a lot of politically
incorrect songs.
He was from the north of
England, I should add, the
same part of the world
as The Beatles.
He had a goofy grin
and big teeth.
He spoke in a North
country accent.
He used to say, he's turned
out nice again, he-he-he.
My uncle read some
of his songs.
My uncle wrote the A-side of
this next song, but it didn't
become a hit.
My uncle wrote "Do
De O Do Blues."
I hope that wasn't
objectionable.
I don't think so.
It's just harmless stuff.
But, of course, in those days,
British were so insular they
didn't care about offending
anybody.
And I guess it's not really
offensive, actually.
But we had our empire.
And we've lost our empire now.
Anyway, it won't excuse this
song, except I think his
playing is very good.
I hope we have some
more questions.
I've really enjoyed talking
to you all.
I thoroughly approve
of Google.
You're wonderful.
I wish I understood
the computer more.
I have a terrible trouble
with typing now
because of my illness.
Every other word is a mistake.
Every other word I type comes
out as a typo, so I have to
keep going back.
By the way, if you're
interested, I write regularly
on my website a thing called
"Letter from Lotusland." I've
done that for 20 years now.
There's even a book out, which
you can get on Amazon, called
"Letters from Lotusland." And
if you just put it into
Google, just put "Letters from
Lotusland," you'll see Ian
Whitcomb's "Letter from
Lotusland." And every month, I
write about what I've
been doing.
People seem to enjoy it
all over the world.
I've talked so much about
myself haven't I?
But anyway, my wife is
a wonderful singer.
It's on that record, called
"Legends of Ukulele." And once
I was up in Oregon at a folk
festival, and this woman said
she was going to
play this song.
And I said, I'll play it.
She said, no I'd like to it.
And she sang it in the most
beautiful, straight away.
And I thought it's just the most
wonderful thing if you're
a songwriter if you're somebody
else you don't know
sing your songs.
It's just so heartwarming.
[APPLAUSE]
IAN WHITCOMB: All right,
thank you.
I just want to say that, since
we're in Venice, I play most
Sundays at a restaurant in
Playa Del Rey called
Cantalini's Salerno Beach
Italian Restaurant.
It's very popular.
We play from 6:30 'til
9:30, not every week.
I'll be there this Sunday.
But it's really nice.
Lots of people come to that.
It's a lovely, delightful,
no expensive.
It's a nice little
intimate place.
And I play with Fred Sokolow,
the guy you just heard playing
the slide guitar and guitar, and
a bass player and myself.
And sometimes Regina
comes down.
It's on Culver Boulevard in
Playa Del Rey, a nice part of
the world, Cantalini's, Salerno
Beach, Cantalni's.
AUDIENCE: There's a link
in the Wikipedia entry.
IAN WHITCOMB: Oh there is?
Well, if you get a
chance, if you're
interested, do look me up.
I've got so many things
on YouTube.
It's endless.
I hope they stay up there.
Some of them shouldn't be there,
perhaps, but anyway.
But I'm very happy
to be on YouTube,
tons and tons of stuff.
And all my books are
available there.
I've written about 18 books.
The one that's the most fun,
I think, is "Letters from
Lotusland," which is on Amazon
and something called Lulu.
So anyway, are there
any questions now?
I've really enjoyed
talking to you.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering what you
think about someone like
Jake Shimabukuro.
IAN WHITCOMB: Wonderful player,
Japanese, he's virtuosic.
He doesn't sing.
He's playing the concert,
virtuosic style, which is
completely different to what
I was playing today.
I was playing the singers
who accompany
themselves on the uke.
Jake is a wonderful player,
nice fellow.
And he's playing the virtuosic,
virtuoso, playing
tunes on the ukulele, which is
completely different to what I
was playing.
But, I mean, there's
room for us all.
Ukulele is a very versatile
instrument indeed.
Any more questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Any history of
ukulele in the blues?
IAN WHITCOMB: I don't think it
lends itself to the blues.
It's too happy and jolly.
It doesn't get blue,
the ukulele.
Although there is a book, Fred
Sokolow's put out a book of
playing the blues
on the ukulele.
But, to me, it's not really--
its notes are very
short and sharp.
It doesn't really lend
itself to that.
It's just, you know-
[UKULELE PLAYING]
IAN WHITCOMB: [SINGING]
I hate to see, the evening
sun go down.
It's too jolly.
an instrument.
Anyway, any more questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a text from
my cousin in Miami who is a
ukulele player, which is one of
the reasons I actually came
today, because he oftentimes
will bring it to family
gatherings and that
sort of thing.
And he says, probably too late
now, just thank him for me for
bringing the uke to
so many folks.
IAN WHITCOMB: Oh, how good.
That's nice to hear that.
AUDIENCE: And he has a YouTube
video he wants me to share
with you later.
IAN WHITCOMB: Well, in my own
small way, I'm quite popular
throughout the world.
I mean, I've done
so many things.
By the way, what we didn't
mention was I produced a CD
which won a Grammy of the
music played aboard the
"Titanic," which
is a lovely CD.
I decided that I'd worked on
the James Cameron film.
I knew he'd got it all
wrong at the end.
They did not play "Nearer, My
God, to Thee" at the end.
If a ship is sinking,
you don't play that.
You play something
jolly and happy.
So they actually played a song
called "Songe d'Automne." So I
went to Rhino Records, and I
said, look, why don't we make
a record to come out the same
time as "Titanic," the film.
We will have the music that
was actually played
aboard the real ship.
James Cameron was furious.
But our record did extremely
well and won a Grammy Award.
It's a lovely record called
"Titanic, Music as Played on
the Fateful Voyage."
So I've done many,
many things.
I've even, believe it or
not, been in films.
You can see me in the film
"Contact." I played a BBC
reporter in that.
I did the music for "The Cat's
Meow" for Peter Bogdanovich.
And other films which
we won't mention.
But I do act.
I do all these things.
Write my books.
But right now I'm sort
of just trying
to get better, recovery.
But I've really enjoyed talking
to you all today.
So nice to see your
happy faces.
Hope you've enjoyed it too.
Any more questions?
Do we have time still?
AUDIENCE: You did a
couple different
styles of ukulele playing.
I was wondering, since you
mentioned the slide guitar
starting out in Hawaii.
IAN WHITCOMB: Yes, well
that was Hawaiian.
That was my friend Fred was
playing a dobro guitar.
But the earlier Hawaiian
recording was a regular guitar
which they tuned to open
strings, and then he slid a
metal bar along.
That really was a Hawaiian
invention, not from blues at
all, but from Hawaii.
AUDIENCE: Did that change how
people played the ukulele?
IAN WHITCOMB: No, I think they
just strummed along.
I think it's important, when
you've got a slide guitar
playing, you really have
to have the ukulele
play a steady rhythm.
Otherwise it all gets thrown.
You have to have them play
a steady rhythm.
I used to have a very
good strum.
I'm sure it'll come
back in time.
But my strum's a bit rudimentary
right now.
I'm playing this weekend at a
place that's near Cantalina's.
It's called Boulevard Music.
It's a folk place.
With Janet Klein and
her Parlor Boys.
I'm one of her Parlor Boys.
I'm a bit old to be
a boy, but still.
I still play a lot.
I still play all over the place
with my radio shows.
I can see somebody's bursting
with a question.
Are you?
I hope you've all
enjoyed today.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I've asked this from
several who we've spoke to,
what do you want to do
when you grow up?
IAN WHITCOMB: I never
did grow up.
I've never had a proper job.
By the way, I went to university
at Trinity College
in Dublin, which I believe
Google has a big base there
now in the tallest building in
Dublin, which was not there
when I was- I was there
from 1961 to '65.
And Dublin then was a
very old-fashioned,
priest-ridden country.
It was run by the
Catholic church.
You couldn't have
contraceptives there, for example.
So it was still set in
the 18th century.
It was very nice.
The buildings were all
exactly the same.
The pubs were very
old-fashioned.
You'd watch the man pouring your
Guiness, and it was an
art form skimming the top
of the foam off the top.
Pouring a Guiness was
really an art form.
Dublin was a completely
different place then.
If you went to see a film
there, you used to have
commissionaires, men in uniform,
standing outside.
And there were always lines
for films in those days
because everybody wanted
to see films.
And the films were all censored
so they couldn't have
anything that had sex in it.
And so whenever there was a cut
in the film, the audience
would shout out, snip! snip!
Because they thought
it'd been cut.
It was a very old-fashioned
country.
In some ways wonderful,
many ways.
But I had a wonderful time
there, spent most of my time
in pubs and bars.
I took a history degree there
in modern history,
which ended in 1914.
Went from the fall of the
Roman Empire to 1914.
And political science, didn't
learn much from that.
Most of the time I was playing
in bands in Dublin.
But I had a wonderful
time in Dublin.
And my best friends
I met there.
I really loved Ireland.
I still do.
I'm going back there in
August to play at
ukulele hulee there.
Why they've hired me I
don't know because I
can't play very well.
But they're very kind
to me there.
And that's where I made my first
record, which became the
hit, top 10 hit.
In Ireland, it was the first
Irish-made record to ever get
into the charts, which means
there's a link between Ian
Whitcomb and U2.
I don't think they like
that connection much.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How hard is
it for a guitar
player to play the ukulele?
IAN WHITCOMB: It'd be
going backwards.
It's much simpler to play.
It's much simpler than playing
guitar to get a basic strum
and find those figures.
It's easy.
That's why so many people- there
are clubs all over Los
Angeles, I go to them.
And they meet once a week,
these strummers.
And they all sit there, and they
play every kind of song
from "Bridge Over Troubled
Water" to whatever.
And they sit there and they
strum and they sing.
It's a joyous sight to see.
The ukulele brings nothing
but smiles.
It's a really happy
instrument.
I love it.
I've had some very happy moments
playing the ukulele
and writing songs.
I still write songs.
I mean, songwriting
is really what I'm
interested in most of all.
But when I say songwriting, I
mean songs that have proper
tunes and words.
I know I sound old-fashioned,
but I can't get along with the
rap today and hip hop
because it doesn't
need to have any tunes.
I mean, if you want to analyze
rap, Winston Churchill was
actually a rapper because he
just spoke without tunes.
We shall fight them
on the beaches.
I mean, that's rapping too.
He rapped.
FDR rapped, too.
The only thing we have to
fear is fear itself.
That's rapping, really.
But rapping has nothing
to do songwriting,
that's what I'm saying.
It may be saying some
important things.
I'm not against it from that.
But the point is it's nothing
to do with music.
And I've said enough opinions.
And I'm sure I've shocked
you all today.
I'm a man of many opinions.
Thank you very much indeed.
And don't forget, help
yourself to the
books and the CDs.
Anything on stage except my
uke is for you, thank you.